if wormholes exist they're probably
pretty fragile meaning if you or any
matter entered one of these tunnels in
space-time the Wormhole would collapse
and now we know just how fast that
collapse might happen in a new computer
simulation a physicists modeled a
spacecraft diving through a wormhole as
expected the probe triggered the
wormholes collapse cinching the tunnel
shut and leaving behind something like a
black hole but the cosmic cave-in
happened slow enough that a probe could
send a light speed signal back Through
the Wormhole before it closed so a
spacecraft sent through a wormhole may
not be able to come back but it could in
theory offer us a glimpse of the other
side before saying goodbye